Welcome To The Sky News Daily I'm Neil
Patterson for five days now the world
has been waiting to hear from the five
people stuck on board a deep sea
submersible that went missing on its way
down to see the Titanic
but on Thursday afternoon the U.S Coast
Guard announced it had located debris in
the search area
an ROV a remote operated vehicle
discovered the tail cone of the Titan
submersible approximately 1600 feet
from the bow of the Titanic on the sea
floor
the ROV subsequently
found additional debris
in consultation with experts from within
the unified command
the debris is consistent with the
catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber
upon this determination we immediately
notified the families
sadly this tragedy was not entirely
unexpected back in 2018 industry experts
warned that the vessel called Titan was
not safe to complete its Titanic
expedition the body representing the
manned underwater Vehicles industry the
Marine technology Society sent a letter
to Ocean Gate the company that designed
Titan in part it reads thus our
apprehension is that the current
experimental approach adopted by Ocean
Gate could result in negative outcomes
from minor to catastrophic that would
have serious consequences for everyone
in the industry
I'll be speaking with Skies John Sparks
who's at the very center of those
recovery efforts in Newfoundland you
know money gets them there but it
doesn't get them out but first i'm
joined in the studio by rear Admiral Dr
Chris Parry himself a former Royal Navy
Warfare officer who spent a career on
the sea coordinating search and rescue
efforts he was also been keenly watching
the rise of these new submersive
Technologies
let's talk about the Titan itself
because having been just just reading
and fascinated and and drawn to the
story as so many other people have an
awful lot of the discussion has been
around the materials used and the design
what is your view of the of the
suitability of this craft so carbon
fiber is really the only material you
can use to go that deep the reason
nuclear submarines can't go that deep is
because they made a steal and big bits
of engineering when you go on these deep
sea Expeditions especially when you go
down to somewhere like four kilometers
everything has to go right every time
nothing can go wrong and what we've seen
in particular with this hole the Titan
is things going wrong continuously we've
heard evidence of people saying well
yeah of course the communications were
lost or the electricity was lost in fact
we did a whole Expedition once without
any communication with at the surface
now they should be warning signs also
when you know that it hasn't been
certified continuously for the last five
years or so down to the depths at which
it is operating just explain the
certification point so this is a largely
unregulated space and people like the
inventor here have put the thing
together they've taken advice on how
they would build the whole they've
actually bolted on their own sort of
electronics their own sort of controls
and he prided himself on the fact that
he could buy this stuff from Camping
World and have sort of games controllers
to actually control the thing well
that's great now my experience is if you
have these sorts of vehicles in high
pressure and high risk scenarios you not
only have to have very robust integrated
electronics and controls you also need
redundancy and backup it explain the
concept of redundancy because again a
lot of people have been talking about
this essentially you have a a series of
fail safes yeah all of which have to to
be triggered for the the worst case
scenario to unfold yeah you see I
believe Titan was constructed and
configured on the basis that hey the
norm is it'll go okay it doesn't seem to
be any consideration of what happens
when it goes wrong it's not tethered for
example like most our remote operating
vehicles are seems to have had some sort
of device for saying I'm okay every 15
minutes it doesn't have a black box type
recorder which pings away saying here I
am and it seems that there's been very
LAX procedures and operations so for
example in the past it's disappeared for
an hour and a half and basically come
back up again and so I had a problem it
sounds like the operators have been have
been rather too sanguine but but we even
wouldn't even a kind of a homemade kind
of submersible of this type have some
facility just to flick a switch and get
it straight to the surface I mean it's
pressurized isn't it so you wouldn't
necessarily have to worry about the
bends essentially what happens is you
descend by syncing and you've got
weights on the skids underneath face and
when you want to ascend you actually
drop the weights the sandbags you only
use the little Motors on the side to
actually maneuver around when you're at
depth so it's very unsophisticated in
that respect but what has worried me
over the last few years hearing about
these operations is that they've had a
malfunction that malfunction has been
detected on the surface and they've
continued with the tour around Titanic
and come back six seven hours later well
that is fundamentally bad practice so
there's all sorts of areas here where
red flags should be popping up including
right at the top of the list you have to
sign a disclaimer saying that the
company is not responsible for emotional
damage trauma injury or death would that
not be would that not be typical in
extremes I was going to call it an
extreme sport but adventuring excursions
of of this type that there is always a
risk energy jumping is the same yeah but
you know when I've seen bungee jumping
just claimers it says these are the
risks are you accepting these risks and
I haven't seen any documentation in
relation to this company that said these
are the risks this is what could go
wrong these are the margins we're
operating to milder worry relates to the
hull itself I haven't seen any
documentation or certification that says
that that Hull is safe nor have I seen
any indication there has been
non-destructive testing after each dive
to see if there's a distortion or
there's a crack in the system the letter
written on March the 27 2018 for the
Marine technology Society outlines an
awful lot of the concerns you've just
been mentioning but but you see that
this submersible this organization is
doing so in what is largely an
unregulated Space by which I'm taking it
that you mean you know anyone could do
this it depends which jurisdiction
you're operating in um so if you and I
did it um then I think the UK
authorities would take an interest but
I'm thinking that the ship that put in
in the water the support ship the polar
Prince is Canadian flagged so I'd be
looking right now what the regulations
are for ships operating on the high seas
in relation to the flag State rules
okay let's focus a little more on the
recovery operation of course being
coordinated from that small island off
the coast of Canada and our
International correspondent John Sparks
has been reporting from there John just
just describe to me exactly where you
are and what you've been seeing well
we're in the capital of Newfoundland St
John's it is a port city the capital
city of this province experiencing
really terrible weather since uh since
January setting all sorts of Records in
the wrong way for low temperatures and
and rainfall that sort of thing you've
been in St John's for a few days now
you'll no doubt have been speaking to to
many of the people who actually live
there who themselves must either have
family friends who earn their living
from being out on those those very very
dangerous Waters I mean I'm wondering
how they are viewing what is happening
at the moment people they know the sea
here in Newfoundland their livelihoods
to a certain extent depend on it and
they're also they're wary of it you know
many ways it it it frightens them and
then for good reason in a positive way
everybody here has been touched by by
tragedies at Sea by by disasters perhaps
the most famous one being a storm a
massive storm that flipped over an oil
platform in the early 1980s called the
ocean Ranger more than 50
newfoundlanders were were killed in that
people know what the sea can do they
know the risks they know the
consequences of of the huge storms of
the North Atlantic swell which which
batters the the island I think another
interesting thing is that you know
they've also grown used to these these
Expeditions out to the Titanic site yeah
we're having a really interesting
conversation with a local businessman
and it is how is taking photographs of
various ships and vessels and he was
pointing out look you know we've had
different groups and organizations and
companies running these these trips
these Expeditions out to the Titanic
site since it was discovered in 1985
must be an awful feeling to see the
clock pass
every minute you know every year the the
ships have been departing on these
Expeditions whether it was
a Canadian flag or or you know they used
to be Russians and they were French and
they were different nationalities that
have that had submarines on board become
almost normal to see very normal I mean
that's uh doesn't raise an eyebrow it's
become routine here you see these people
from all over the world often very
wealthy people going out to the site
putting themselves in submersibles or
submarines and then going down to the
wreck and in many cases pulling up
artifacts pulling up small bits of the
the ship you know and some of those
artifacts have ended up in John's he he
was telling me that there has been a
trade in the bars in and around Saint
John's of of bits of the ship Changing
Hands you know that that doesn't happen
now it's a bit more regulated a treaty
preserving the site was passed in the
United States in 2019 I think that was
ratified in the UK this year so it's
more regulated now but there has been
this this industry really of taking
people to the site getting them down to
the site so people can have a look you
know more than more than 100 I think
around 150 people you know have been
down there and and basically that's what
this guy who was running Ocean Gate
stopped and Rush that's what he was
doing he had this idea right I'm gonna
make the Titanic site much more
accessible I've got this craft
it can get down there I can get people
to Newfoundland I can get them on it I
can charge them 250 000 a seat
and um I'm going to turn it into a
business and I think
nobody really really noticed it here
because that sort of thing is has been
going on for for years since 1985. do
you get the fascination with Titanic and
the the excitement the pursuit of
excitement the the thrill seeking that
these people will have had to to go down
to those depths to to put your life on
the line I have to admit I'd never do it
yeah well I you know I think you know a
lot of us are thinking that now you'd
never get us in a submersible like this
absolutely no way there's a close
equivalent with with space tourism you
have businessmen entrepreneurs providing
new tourism opportunities for for the
well-heeled that really pushed the
limits that really go beyond anything
that we've seen before you know those
things are accessible now space the site
of the Titanic four kilometers
underneath the surface of the ocean in
the North Atlantic it's really it's
really pushing the limits and we've seen
the problem now you know we've seen the
problem which is it's extreme and what
makes it extreme is the fact that if
they get into trouble it's really
difficult for anybody to do anything
about it I mean you know arguably this
is this is beyond the capacity of
governments or militaries or coast
guards certainly private companies to
get people out of trouble quickly and
and and this is the proof of that
they're going to places where it's very
difficult to go and get them if things
go wrong and
and they're taking an enormous Risk by
doing it that you know money gets them
there but it doesn't get them out
okay Chris Patty let's return to you for
a second as we've mentioned the debris
has now been found do you think given
what we have seen that there will be
people making that trip in other
submersibles of course but making that
trip to Titanic anytime soon I don't
think anytime soon I think there's going
to be a real clamp down on the sector
that's the first thing and secondly
people are going to want a lot of
assurance that there are backups in case
things go wrong I always stress to
people the C is always out to get you
doesn't matter what depth you're at at
my experience of commanding ships of
flying over the sea if you turn your
back it'll get you
um and you've got to be on on your
Lookout all the time if you're going
down four kilometers into into the ocean
where the pressure is two tons per
square inch and until you get that
Assurance you shouldn't be doing this no
none of us should be doing it and I and
I ask people today would you go down in
that narrow tube to four kilometers
bolted in with 17 bolts tiny porthole
just to get close to something you can
see virtually anyway on the internet I
don't think I would have you ever known
anyone to to even consider going down to
those depths oddly enough an
acquaintance of mine contacted me just
when this broke and said I won the
lottery last year
and I wrote to this company saying I
really want to visit the Titanic can I
go on this season I've seen all the
rumors and all this documentation of can
you assure me it's safe and are you
certified below 3000 meters company
didn't reply
now we've asked Ocean Gate to respond to
the claims raised in this podcast and at
the time of recording are still waiting
to hear from them but in response to the
allegations raised back in 2018 by the
Marine technology Society Ocean Gates
posted the blog the following year
saying that Titan had not been classed
because it believed the classification
process could inhibit Innovation and
that it failed to address pilot error it
went on to insist that it carried out a
detailed risk assessment for every dive
taking 25 specific factors into account
and resulting in a dive plan to mitigate
against known risks
and that is your lot for this edition of
The Daily our new Patterson my thanks to
both Chris Pally and John Sparks this
Edition was produced by silent aparisio
and Sydney Pete our editor is Adam G
foreign